i notice on a man one is height duh what
about you forearms back posture
in that order
height
uh smile probably eyes depending on the
guy whatever is nicer if his my eyes are
nicer i'll notice that first then smile
a lot of girls say
teeth on a guy smile
and i never notice teeth and i know most
guys don't get their teeth fixed it's
more of a if it is us like up the
genders women get their teeth done more
but like i i remember my ex told me he
purposely grew out a beard because he
hated his teeth and so i told guys if
you have bad teeth but you can grow a
beard do it like the long beard i don't
like beards yeah they're gross
i don't know but i think most girls do
i'm in the minority like most girls like
beards yeah they're gross to me
but like i'll still date somebody that
has it i guess
i don't know it's hot and then it's not
i'm not very consistent
um sir what is your username
what's it say i don't want to say
okay turn if you want to come on turn
your camera on
um girls always compliment my smile but
rolo says it's more of a female trait
well i think i like profiles it is i i
think i like more feminine looking guys
like i don't when i when i looked at
that
there was a guy who broke down like
attractiveness into like more masculine
features and more feminine features and
like though i liked the guys that were
more feminine featured i don't know why
i think a lot of people forget that
like feminine features on guys like what
is seen as more feminine or beta or
whatever somebody wants to say it it's
going to be the opposite when you're on
birth control so like not under control
okay so
for women that let's say
i see a guy that's feminine
he's technically
masculine if she's on birth control oh
really yeah so and people think like oh
if she's technically ovulating
she would see it it's one of those
things that like still kind of confuses
me but i remember
brought it up in the episode with rolo
and she said um i think it's a problem
that women are put on birth control at a
young age and they think they're
attracted to one thing get off birth
control and then they go for the
opposite
yeah
i don't know no i've like worth
controlling years so
i like i've specifically stayed off of
it as much as i can to be honest i was
on it for a couple years but
i don't know i was on and off of it for
sure but
now that i don't have sex
i'm good
yeah almost
365
days damn
not of choice
not him
georgia yes it is of choice no it's not
i've just
isolating myself i know what i'm saying
like you know there's people that you
could sleep with if you wanted to sleep
with someone yeah but i don't i've never
had a one-night stand pearl i would have
a panic attack i know i know
i know but i'm saying that's a choice
i guess maybe not you think
like you think you couldn't well nobody
hits me up
for sure
what do your dm's look like [ __ ]
empty maybe more today because it's my
birthday and people have been sending me
messages but usually empty yeah see
everybody is
you can see some sending me a birthday
message i don't know if you can see my
phone's gonna die
hello
one of them's me
yeah
but everything's happy birthday but
before that like no
dud ass people will send me things like
about the shower topic ideas or
something my gosh do you know what i
felt like this dm i got today
look at this
this man um okay i just got a weird dm
someone dm me i told my parents about us
i don't know i know
for sure okay go with it what would you
normally say do a question mark i think
no this man has nothing like that oh
actually i shouldn't show his username
but like i'm either
send me their profile i'll tell you
where it is right now
we could
oh my gosh no um
yeah this guy has been sending me high
since like 2017.
are you going to respond yet
no
why not he's put into work
um my my my instagram is just and then
dot pearly things i'll put in the chat
we should live stream i wish my like on
instagram too
i wish i knew where a charger was you
bumped the stream i know
thank you i never get this many people
in my lives
how many people are in thank you that
was so nice of you
um there's
somebody
oh no rolo put oh he's in this stream
yeah
baby daddy
okay give give me people to smash or
pass i'll do it too
uh
rolo i could have asked you that before
you said pass yeah pass but please but
please but please keep bumping the
streets okay
don't don't i would get mad at her i'd
get pissed i probably got up if you said
you
would to be honest
no one
okay give me another give me another
erin pass
really
you lying
[ __ ]
really
he has
too much of like um it's just not like
the like the look facially that i go for
like respectfully
no he's good looking i wouldn't want to
[ __ ] him and i said smash
like you can't deny good genes
really you don't think he's not no no i
mean
no he's not okay how do i put it like
he's not a bad looking guy he's just not
like you like more feminine
you're dead
a feminine like looking guy i don't know
give me another lead attorney i would
say has feminine yeah
that would be like easy smash
yeah you love him
yeah i do he's so cute he's good looking
but i don't know i can't smash or pass
people i know already okay give me the
people in the chat no the man of sphere
what's his name the guy that thinks that
we want a bang
what's his name johnson
no he's dumb and he was like oh these
girls are fighting over effing me i'm
like what the sir
when you live in a delusion long enough
you will change whatever a person says
okay kevin ray wilder wilder oh
kevin wait who's
i think i know who that is that the
white pill guy because i think i was on
a live with him once
yeah where you want to go live with him
no no no no you've been on a live with
1400 leis it popped up in my [ __ ]
feet
oh that guy i went to that was the boot
camp i went to okay wait i thought 1400
lays was
guys what's his name lifestyle
yeah anthony i went i went to his boot
camp that was that video i did i thought
that was somebody else that guy looked
like a vampire
that was a different dude
was it a boot camp
i'm confused that was his
the lead attorney is just the steve
harvey of youtube okay well
i accurately i i stand
to be honest i don't know why
um
andrew tate
um
i don't like his personality but he's
he's good looking so smack you don't
like his personality
no
i don't he's high energy i thought you
would well it's more like i just don't
like the things that come out of his
mouth
what is that
uh i don't know
what about dj academics i forgot what he
looks like hold on
i know i've seen him before but i've
never looked that close
uh
andrew probably probably smash
um what andrew schultz
dad shoes
andrew schultz i was
probably smash
um
oh trying to think of who else i don't
know you guys
these from the roommates oh my gosh that
is like
like top five on youtube smash easy i
think he's so really
yeah i think his co-host is cute i don't
know i think they're both cute oh my
gosh
uh
yeah they're both good-looking rollo
gave me justin waller let me see
you know who justin waller waller is
he's like the ginger archetype for me
that's what everyone says
oh him pass
um i'm just not he's tall
is he he doesn't he doesn't look tall i
don't look at you
he's tall i've never seen him it's just
like a from a picture quick is it
because he's a ginger he's a good
[ __ ] dude i actually think you would
really like him i'm surprised you said
no
um
russell brand uh pass
what about you russell brand
has maybe back in the day but now that
he's like a new woke boy no like with
all due respect i he's catering to those
people and that's great
he has a good way of
kind of favoring both sides when really
favoring
the wolf culture by
verbalizing it i don't know he kind of
talks a lot and i talk a lot so i don't
i don't think it'd work
chris who else this is fun
tristan tate
um you look like tristan tate um his
name sounds like a cracker
it's andrew tate's brother i would do
smash yeah
wait but you don't like andrew no i said
i said like looks alone smash i just
don't like oh
so because i've heard him like talk it
would be like like why would i want to
sleep with a guy that says i want to f
like
people in front of their girlfriends
like that's weird when did he say that
it was a view i reacted to
that's crazy [ __ ] tate gosh there's
so many charlemagne the god smasher pass
yes
uh looks alone smash but i i don't
know after like that thing he was
involved in that was weird
um
like the underage girl
yeah yes somebody was on their show that
was gonna come on my show talk about
crypto some episode lebron james pass
sorry guys i know you guys like sports
[Laughter]
everyone i would smash is maybe like
steve nash or something
i would smash still brian james drake
kanye uh
pass pass
actually maybe kanye only because i'd
want him to like fix me up he made kim
you know he really elevated her i could
use it
actually think i would date kanye you
would date kanye's too short for me
like five eight i think five seven
um
sterling cooper uh
probably oh
probably would if i didn't know that he
was a porn star
[Laughter]
so i know i don't know i don't know who
that is
look him up he's got a pretty popular
channel pass uh richie cooper pass i'm
not i don't
he looks like my ex like i can't even
lie [ __ ] cooper is like
he's not bad looking it's just like my
preference isn't the age gap thing
that's like not
but let's say you could only look at
them
wait age gap thing
like i'm not
like a lead attorney is old i know but
he doesn't look old
but i think i don't think rich looks
that old either
does he
i'm like trying to not be rude